in Counter Strike global Offensive the
major is everything there are other big
tournaments with their own prestige and
their own history but majors are in a
class of their own the prize pool and
the bragging rights stand apart and
until January North America had yet to
win a single one like this was the joke
that we had all weekend long where it's
like Kazakhstan a team won the major
yeah we're at now in a ya know in a woo
physics time you know yeah yeah North
America what is going on here at the 11
prior official valve majors only six na
teams had made it out of the main group
stage only one had reached the grand
final team liquid whose roster was
majority American but anchored by
Ukrainian superstar Alexander simple
castelia that team made an incredible
run at Cologne 2016 but it ended when
they felt a Brazilian powerhouse
sk-gaming the constant and a heartbreak
had to have a source but it was
difficult to pinpoint exactly what that
might be and so that the talent is there
in the United States what's always been
the hold up it seems is the buyouts how
expensive it is how expensive it would
be and so or or you just kind of have to
cheat a little bit and go full liquid
and get one of the best European players
out there and and maybe use him as a
stand-in given North America's history
at the majors fans were less than
hopeful that the streak would be broken
in Boston but the region's best bet was
on cloud nine the team had gone through
changes in August of 2017 with nothing
and shroud leaving the roster which
seemed to highlight internal strife kind
of couple weeks before it ended I kind
of felt there was definitely an internal
conflict in the team things like that
are kind of bound to happen you got
different
age levels different maturity levels so
stuff like that she's found to come out
don't point getting a team stuff I
believe that there's no teams
there is always kind of a barrier right
and this is the unwritten rule when it
comes to players is that whatever is
happening in the team you don't talk
about it with that it's like mob
families or whatever right whatever's
happening in the family that's family
business and you are not hearing about
it right you're not talking about that
to anybody else it's not much to talk
about really two weeks ago or something
I messaged Jack and I was like hey Jax
the owners you know by the way I was
like hey I kind of want to step down I
would love to be here guys his backup I
want to see where full-time stream takes
me and he was super supportive he's like
let's do it let's make it happen let the
record state that I asked to see myself
out replacing them Mort Eric and rush
who had recently completed a stint with
optic gaming that included several
high-profile victories an AR it's it's
kind of dire I'm not really sure I don't
really have all that much faith in this
new cloud nine because it seems like
they're still playing hot potato with
union leader role the move may not have
inspired confidence initially but public
opinion eventually began to turn and the
team started putting up promising
results at the perfect time the months
preceding the Boston major set for
January 2018 the strength of those
results even led several analysts to
rank them among the majors top five
teams because the roster still included
three players who had helped the team
achieve a 9th 11th finish at the
previous major in Krakow they were
automatically qualified for the Boston
majors new challengers stage it used a
Swiss format and c9 quickly put up wins
against NV sprout and mousesports to
earn their spot in the new legend stage
fans held their breath though the team
had another swiss group stage to make it
through it was an encouraging
performance so far but things
immediately got worse
gamers could doodle by the way six kills
against this unlikely based on that stat
line but it would be the best thing he's
done all game flashed off in the open
there is the peak there's the flashback
very important outcomes and Taurus gets
nothing down to pass picks rush out the
end now another one from past what else
oh goodness pass from him oh my god the
ACE to take the match Oh could you ask
for an ace at a better moment pass
stepping up unbelievable
down Oh to cloud nine look like they
would continue n A's major legacy by
bombing out yeah that first half it
seems like some of the problems that
they they left I left them when I was
off the team still there you know even
even watching the last round there I I
saw I come stood behind the players as I
got ready to get on the desk and it just
seemed like they were kind of upset
they're probably gonna do an interview
and say they felt like they should have
won because some of the rounds at the
very last round they lost tarik there's
a miscount Russia suppose we open the PK
hall or something and then tarik wait I
think you hold the push I don't I don't
know if they started getting in heads a
little bit but for some members of c9
likes to e2k being Oh to changed
something nothing after the space
soldiers game it was a big wake-up call
for me like I said I think it kind of
lighted it lit the fuel for me that's
where the fire started happening my DM
doll night I would play and I think only
got a few hours of sleep the next day
but that's something I'm willing to
sacrifice if it makes me play better and
from there I just kind of didn't look
back and played on my own game only yeah
yesterday like doesn't the g2 fine you
know we lost you to whatever losing to
space soldiers is a big hit because once
you go to you know like [__] hit the fan
and and you know like now it's
elimination matches only with their
tournament life now on the line they
first played against virtus Pro another
Oh two team thanks to the Swiss format
c9 put up a convincing sixteen seven
effort on Mirage and lived to fight
another day
here is one frag and then it really
becomes very difficult for ties he
crosses straight into the cross has no
trade oh this is so hard for snacks
candy to it
goes around the corner meet systemize at
the hands of skadoodle and that's 15
navicomp I'm next Astor all Asst a team
that had won the previous elite major in
Atlanta but struggled to find their form
as an injury to device affected their
fortunes but even with device back the
c9 overcame the Danish roster quickly
rotate to each bomb site both of them
with eyes on a high grand man show they
spotted him they definitely knew one
dares to kill sixty and six and
Charlotte sent packing from cloud nine
who continued now to two there was only
one single obstacle between North
America and the bracket stage Vega
squadron a surprise in their own right
Vega was a CIS team that had been
together for a long time but failed to
show up against tier 1 teams one of the
Cinderella runs had to end time to deny
the plant gets spotted by Wang though he
could do this please go no cap donates
and he's gotta find 2 kills which are
opposites yeah 20 again no the HPI jumps
across rush deals at 16 rounds for cloud
9 and one final legend status spot for
skadoodle cloud 9 to the zombies now in
the bracket and on the big stage cloud 9
we're playing on home soil
[Music]
[Applause]
they would need to win a best-of-three
against g2 eSports to move on and
despite their earlier loss to the French
powerhouse they didn't just win
they won convincingly what SK gaming
would be their opponents in the
semi-finals and that team had been on a
tear of their own before the tournament
albeit with bolts in place of the mp9 as
Moses you hate to see him not me they
have to go for this they can't afford to
get away at their backs get it over with
the angle one more coming one more to
deal with it's just taco no kit and he's
been tagged down to 40 HP goes for the
fight after a dominant game one
performance by cloud 9 sk struck back
three buses for with the farm down at
cloud nine trying to hold on to this map
and prevent the third one from coming in
they're just waiting right now as first
meets up behind gets one more kettle
water Buster coming through the quad
till they cannot stop him 15 rounds here
for SK gaming but a standout performance
when Derrick helped to boost his team
and c9 made it through to the front
right now the Guilford territories the
weapon he gets a car
their last opponent the super team
roster a faze clan the team that seemed
all but destined to lift the trophy in
Boston while North America was still
looking for their first major win phases
olofmeister already boasted - of course
it will be very fun to win three and to
join the likes of pronax
yet ugly inflation but that squad still
had players hungry for their first
including veteran offer Guardian and
superstar youngin Nikko on home soil
with the bewildered but exhilarated
crowd behind them cloud nine went to
work there are chances here for face
card is watching the cross destroy may
be the only chance the Guardian comes
back in Oh God idiot
- there's still more to go but now they
must plot the bomb the peaks come in but
Guardian will not stop one more to go
and Guardian yes then all is up placing
with the mp9 he could be in for quite
the money-making mission he's gonna
describe the ball
the mp9 money in the bank twisted doodle
and again he's on his own they know
they're focusing on the a slight the
smokes down school sort as he making
play through Julie is here there are
smoke everywhere does have the right
angles down goes Nico
the box getting cards and quickly but
the flags are Frank free for everyone
it's good do two on the site Lily find a
sort bear yes but can I go back no
minister son three versus three the bomb
is down automatic still on the a fight
that a time for some reason may be
looking for a lurker this is absolute
client this breaks going away and I said
decipher dad's Guardian automatic on his
own running up the short position I
think what advice is hurt him which
means that they can all hold angles
that's both face the fact that won't
work out face class take the first map
of this series in a close map phase
claimed victory on Mirage na was one map
away from elimination from missing
another major title after losing their
own map pick but cloud nine didn't back
down
taking phases own map of overpass away
from them
Guardian leaving Navi rain has been on
his team since the beginning since the
absolute beginning of his team Kerrigan
leaving a Stronach turret as well he's
got a lot to prove
and he's trying to do so relentless
aggressive doesn't matter what the
situation are that's thirty but
IPE italic cursive since RP popping up
this looks like it is going to be very
very painful SD the grief is there that
crap off Nick over to f3 that's
absolutely absurd that's traumatic from
Nico exactly what they need is how on
earth perhaps phase 1 that round single
is from every single angle right now
more different points of attack
potentially Guardian he's gonna come
self up there tap in position to exploit
his place through the smoke character
undiscovered where's the refract Olaf
wiser not close enough to deal the
damage an automatic can reset the
situation is tarek waits patiently
[Applause]
[Music]
and map three Inferno had never seen a
contest between these two teams the
resulting game was well it's unlikely
we'll ever see another one like it well
they left open coordinate may have been
paid miss Reed because in the coast
cloud line but allspice has something to
say three kills that's a great defense
from here in Guardian starts to get in
on the action as well phased finally
have their time to overwhelm their
opponent cloud line they were funneled
into death and destruction
so Nikko the Molotov is not damaging
here he gets the first kill running
distraction now is he making try to hide
a pop out afterwards because forecast is
there as well and Guardians back in that
the B bombs i bonito tarragon Toni
correcting down Guardian through the
smoke automatic is said to cut off the
rotations and it's another rounded about
kafei's plan that now is about we take
care
are they gonna play against a rock face
plant because in 18 seconds the bomb
goes down again
it's got to be collected but there are
so many CDs running around someone's
gonna collect the form of God's it is be
collected Tara take it in the face
Kerrigan gets punctured as well skeletal
muscle the line it could be too right
mister climbing's right brain to the
live in the Randy's death round lumber
sniffing for Grad Night in face plan
moving to 13 grounds they are looking
really good for it right now
well mine are having a very hard time
they're up against a war their economy
it's not in a good place to he did his
best
it wasn't enough this time how much do
they have left in the tank down 49 cloud
nines hopes look dim but they would not
be stopped
on them really badly Tarek thanking
someone to peek from the balcony
position announced he plays because it's
woodsy arts area but automatic it's
hunting Nico getting tagged a flying
match second is Darius sorry
it's fight versus one they have a lot of
single player I love my sister maybe
offering a fake swords to be bombs like
me want to first convince award base
good deed under the smokes doodle taken
that Terrence got to go huge here he's
got a crossfire with Rush we've got
Guardian in the short position and he's
exposed but he goes down rushed their
life for versus free just putting one
player maybe two toward our position
that would have wives on short but it's
a fast
and he's taken down Tara it's not done
with this major yet they stay alive for
one fall around he's gonna stay alive
about ten seconds first ones to go down
he must be like Juiz it's going
absolutely crazy on the bebop site
there's no time to fly the [__] it's too
late
[Applause]
but I will do the math explain towards
they nothing else is going on he's gonna
go back
[Applause]
over time in a major clinched by an
outnumbered stewey 2k madness c9 had won
six of seven rounds to force their
comeback and in the first overtime and
looked like that momentum was clearly
with them but Guardian desperately
forced a second OT through construction
talked about the kinder pool rain take
it out two on two now an asterick he's
got high hopes but it's not broken down
he goes it's Guardian he's the only man
standing between cloud nine and the
major number two collapse I don't do it
they're still in this phase of a plan
that ot began with the last second
defuse time is starting to run low here
for face might have to move forward
skadoodle repositioning after the first
crack it's both now from quad here for
face can can't lie close it skadoodle
get one skadoodle card get the third it
sneak over 12 is their time mode is
their time I'm not sure if they're it's
gonna be a close one and he's gonna face
five number 10 but c9 pulled ahead they
were on match point there are positive
for class 9 now 5 verses 12 to take it
up or question high ground
jumping off they need to help
construction are there flashes there
will a push
they'll regret the garden rake remain
automatic pushing through its guardian
verses to be dirty chemistry's position
before to win face and brown a very
important very crucial one County
tonight are buying shots Guardian waits
patiently as cloud my scepter pushup
[Applause]
your chopper
[Music]
[Applause]
has to be one of the most incredible
storylines we've ever had a North
American team in North America with a
major win as the team lifted the trophy
and the typically quiet skadoodle
offered up the postgame interview it was
nearly too surreal na had a major win
[Music]
but it wasn't to last whether it was the
issues that nothing spoke of or simply a
wealth of new opportunities that cloud9
roster that one in Boston didn't make it
to the London major intact after losing
in the grand finals of CS summit to
Stewie 2k left to play with Brazilian
squad SK gaming and after being such a
huge part of the team's run at Boston
Tarek left the team in July to join
Stewie on the roster now called MIB R
although they were unable to defend
their major title c 9 drew first blood
for the region they showed us what is
likely the greatest major grand final
series so far they did it against some
of the strongest teams in CS and fans
never
we've ever had thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button